need motivation what's the thing with
belief nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something greater
inside you as well you've got Michael
Jordan level talent at something so get
ready to model success use every
experience to learn and don't be too
hard on yourself
with Timothy sha'lame and my take on his
top ten rules of success to give you the
confidence motivation and belief that
you need enjoy okay let's kick it off
with real number one model success Chris
Nolan is somebody that you may have had
not the big starring Rowan interests but
you're the son of Matthew McConaughey's
character and you don't seem to be
afraid to take parts that saying I even
if I'm in it for three scenes it's worth
me having this time and that's why I did
a part like I did in hostiles which is
in like a huge part or anything but I
wanted to watch how Christian Bale works
on a set for a month and a half because
he's an incredible actor and sure enough
there are things I can you know feel me
not necessarily steal but just even the
you know the idea that it's a marathon
and not a sprint and the way she shows
up on set every day he's ready to go and
it doesn't reach for anything in a scene
which is you know the privilege of
getting to be leads in a movie for 20-30
years but as a young actor you know
you're reaching all the time and so to
watch him go to work it's that was an
insane experience and it's something I'm
totally a bad did even though the role
is not huge but I just wanted to be
around those veterans and those greats
rule number two use every experience to
learn people who would be watching this
interview some of them are starring
actors and really I don't you know so
maybe few words for them you know the
world is your oyster and everything's a
learning experience I think I was
talking about that was like a good actor
from the other day
how like even to audition is an
opportunity to get in front of people
and practice your craft or at the very
least even if you're in a bad headspace
or something an opportunity to learn how
to act in it in a bad headspace sort of
being in pressure-cooker environment so
that experience is the greatest teacher
I guess rule number three I
I think it's adaptability that's like
the strongest suit you can have as an
actor the experience working with Luca
Guadagnino is different than the
experience working with Greta Gerwig it
was different from the experience
working with Christopher Nolan and as an
actor particularly if you're not the
leader the project you try to make
yourself as clay-like as malleable as
possible
a blip in the radar a Wallflower
somebody who's comes prepared and is
ready to go and maybe have an idea or
trick up your sleeve something you want
to try out but ultimately
responsibilities to the character for
the story to that sequence of that day
and just trying to do the best out as
possible rule number four don't be too
hard on yourself
are you very judgmental on the work
because you're doing it I'm not as I'm
doing it there's a great quote by a nun
who turned into an artist in Northern
California I'm forgetting her name but
at the Andy Warhol amusement Museum in
Pittsburgh it's a big quote on the wall
that says creating and analyzing or
separate processes I don't like that
alike so it doesn't mean analyzation
isn't a isn't beneficial to the process
in some at some point when you're
working when you're creating it really
you have to be focused on that and
that's something that drum that
LaGuardia and school for arts and that
high school experience really brought me
because especially performing in front
of a kids your age and it's such a
formative weird awkward time if you can
get up there and fail enough times
consistently and just be bad and just be
like really bad then it just releases
you a little bit more to not analyze as
much because if you like I used to say I
guess I still say something I'm a very
bad practice er of this philosophy the
most important part of an audition is
the second you step out the door because
if you can step out the door and you
treat yourself kindly then the next time
you go in they're gonna be way more free
as opposed to if you kill yourself a
second if you knock yourself sir if you
give your heart of yourself right uh-hum
the second you step out you know you're
gonna clam yourself up more the next
audition you have so I think there's a
process that acting each time like you
know there is gonna be you are gonna be
hard on yourself certainly I'm always
hard on myself and certainly I like
myself into many things but I've been
hard on myself
it'll be hard to bad in that now without
being a masochist sir we watch yourself
also if you want to have more confidence
check out my 254 confident series it's
free the link to join is in the
description below and we have trouble
little God if you want to give up did
you ever feel like that all the time you
thought all the time and then you push
through it for some odd reason I wanted
to kind of go back to square one and
just do it as we done it in the Beatles
my call time is at 7 then you back your
clock up for hours and then that's when
I get up rule number five give your all
I love the combination of being
completely you're great about the
character but at the same time you are
very vulnerable how did you find that
courage how did you find though how did
you prepare for that role oh my eye
I don't know maybe it's like to like
simple or something to point to the
drama school I went to but that's just
like how my whole class was taught is
just to I think if you value like the
idea of being employed and that that's
like an honor it to be able to like
sustain yourself as an artist period not
just factor is like I think inherently
like you got to really give it your all
like I said I think it's responsibility
especially we in this movie and we're
playing real people so I mean this was a
very intimate experience that they went
through so it felt important like - like
I said give it give it everything rule
number six be honest I think honesty and
being as open a book as possible I think
that was the biggest take away from the
drama high school I went to for me was
keep your heart in the sleeve as an
actor that's your instrument your
ability to make yourself an open wound
is what we'll communicate to the
audience and hopefully serve as a
therapeutic device for people experience
something experiencing something similar
to the story will number seven find your
creative process so do you have a method
at this point in terms your acting do
you have a process that you are
committed to or you kind of you know Wow
very fortunate at laguardia we were
exposed to a lot of great QA at a young
age with a bunch of tremendous actors
like Al Pacino and Jake Gyllenhaal and
and Marissa Tomei and they would get
asked that question sometimes about
their process and people would get
really succinct answers but the one I
was related to the most was when he
Falco was asked it and any great actress
Nurse Jackie and Sopranos and somebody
said you know et which process you know
your role and she said you know I have
no idea and it terrifies me each time
and I just do it and that's really the
feeling I have to rule number eight be
prepared to make sacrifices I want to
talk a little bit about your preparation
for beautiful boy well Felix
the director you wanted me to lose
weight at the top how could you lose
weight I know I was like whoa I am
skinny and he was like like you must be
skinnier I lost was must be 15 whoa man
it was 18 no what did you just not eat I
just yeah it's like very hyper
concentrated portions of she's
snowpiercer
yeah I took that protein so what did you
did you yeah it's what you said yeah
it's hard to be eating and like you said
before like I feel like influenced my
environment a lot when I act that's why
I really don't like to act on stages I
want to act like with actual tactile
real things and to just be in that state
was like yeah that was jarring and
jarring for people around me especially
with the makeup - I could come on scent
I would see Steve and he would his face
would drop he told me one day he said no
more he said like I'm he's like you
can't do any more protect yeah
rule number nine don't set yourself up
for failure what is your dream project
was like something that at this point in
your life you're dreaming maybe
something with very book or truthfully
it's long it's how I felt about it like
even my senior year in high school which
was when I was like starting to work
professionally as well was anything good
and that can be musical theater that
could be film that could be TV that
could be
period and to not set oneself up for
failure by you know wanting to do things
that uh or follow a specific path but
rather like to work with writers
directors production designers other
actors that are inspiring in some way or
whose work I've seen before that I've
liked
I'm rule number ten the last one before
a very special bonus clip is have fun
there's a clip of you being a rapper
that I understand that we have that
let's take a look at the clip of you
being a rapper
[Applause]
the backstory behind that is that that
was a school project that he had to
actually turn in for a statistics class
so everyone else wrote out all these big
story statistics papers and all that and
he turned in this awesome rap and the
teacher only gave him like a d-plus oh
now yeah shame on you now I have a
special bonus clip from Timothy on how
to keep challenging yourself that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the three point landing
questions let's go from just watching
the video to taking action here we go
question number one where are you being
too hard on yourself number two what is
your best creative process look like
and number three who are three people
that you can model their success from
and if you liked this video and you're
going to take action after watching it
give me a hashtag believe down in the
comments as well I love watching movies
I love seeing plays even plays or maybe
even a little bit easier for me to read
than screenplays but some when I read
some like a screenplay that really makes
sense it's it's very very clear to me
like beautiful boy something when I read
it that's the film that I did with Steve
Carell then I guess nobody watching this
would have any clue about yet so I'm
speaking without context but that's the
kind of thing when I had to get next
year yeah oh yeah exactly yeah but when
I read that there wasn't the experience
of calling an agent or a friend saying
wow I read this really great script I
can't wait to do it but rather like okay
this is it like how is this gonna happen
roses this can't not happen and I was
kind of filled with calling by her name
and and and and and hopefully projects
going forward but I hope this is the
kind of thing I get to watch a couple
years from now and I can say well I had
disciplined approach to it and you know
like the people I admire like Christian
Bale or Gary Oldman or Saoirse or Emma
Stone or Jennifer Lawrence or Scarlett
Johansson or Myr Herschel you know just
picking the right projects and keep
challenging yourself
if you want my take on Emma Stone's top
ten rules of success check out the video
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there obviously there were a lot of
hopes or dreams that I had and those
things coming true it it kind of